Audacity ist die einzige Software auf meinem Mac,
die es schafft, wenn ich
Airpods drin habe, den Ton
über die System-Lautsprecher auszugeben
und irgendwie nicht mitzukriegen, dass
die Airpods existieren.
Ich weiß nicht, auf welcher Ebene
die die Audiotreiber ansprechen, aber
entscheidend ist das möglich und nur
Audacity kann das.
An Audacity finde ich ja, dass das
von der Übersetzung her eigentlich
zu jeder Haltung, die man zu jeder
Software hat, passt.
Ist das entweder Mut, Kühnheit oder halt auch
Dreistheit, Wack und
Fravorheit.
Das ist ja schön.
Hi Florian.
Hallo.
Hi Kilian.
Hallo Akronomisierbar-Zuhörer.
Das ist Folge
22.
oder 022
akronomisierbar. Diesmal
mit einem weiteren Gast,
nämlich Florian Gicher.
Herzlich willkommen bei unserem
kleinen, gemütlichen, hausgemachten
Podcast.
Und du hast
sehr passend
zu unserem Format bereits
Rants über Messenger
in petto.
Ich weiß großartig.
Den habe ich nicht in petto, den müsste ich zusammenstricken.
Wollen wir mal kurz die Waschmaschine rausmachen?
Ups.
Oh, da muss ich mich schwer zurückhalten.
Ach nee, es ist doch schön, beide Seiten zu beleuchten.
Wenn du meinst, du bist doof, dann reden wir auch darüber.
Nee, ich finde einfach alle Messenger scheiße.
Das sowieso.
Also die Meinung können wir gerne.
Das haben wir gleich auch schnell öfter.
Ich könnte ein bisschen über Riot warnten und warum Matrix.
Was?
Das ist doch die beste Alternative, meiner Meinung nach.
Die kein Mensch verwendet.
Ich bin voll dafür.
Wir können mal kurz den High-Level-Rant
über Messenger machen.
Ich versuche das schon länger zu machen
und Hendrik blockt immer.
Was mache ich?
Du sagst aber auch schon wieder über Messenger.
Irgendwann wiederholen wir uns noch ein bisschen sehr,
aber über Riot haben wir noch nie gerantet.
Nee, also eigentlich möchte ich
nicht über Riot, sondern über Matrix ranten.
Ich will mir gerne mehr Rants in meiner Twitter-Time-Line.
Meine Filter-Bubble
ist eine Rant-Bubble.
Titel vorgleichs.
Der wollte hier nicht einfach
einen Podcast machen, dem nur gewartet werden darf.
Ja. Ich hatte mal eine Weile
in Software-Projekten die Regel,
man durfte über alles warten, wenn man bereit
war, den Fix vorzuschlagen und zu implementieren.
Auch zu implementieren?
Ja, oder zumindest dabei,
also zumindest die Verantwortung
dafür zu übernehmen, dass er implementiert wird.
Suddenly we have 15
Computing Standards.
Aber wenn das jeder macht, dann haben wir morgen 20 neue Chatprotokolle.
Ist doch wunderbar.
Wir haben bereits 20 Chatprotokolle.
Ja, morgen 20 neue.
Das ist eine exponentielle Steigerung, die wir in Chatprotokollen haben.
Aber das ist ja kein Problem, man kann ja alle bridgen.
Das ist die Lösung für alles.
Du musst das einfach mal sagen.
Dann ist es raus.
Ja, also warte mal.
Matrix ist ja eigentlich hauptsächlich dafür da, dass man irgendwie zwischen unterschiedlichen Formaten bridgt.
Nein.
Was?
Die Matrix-Leute sind bloß dabei,
alles bei sich mit reinzubüschen, weil sonst niemand Matrix nutzen würde.
Ach so.
Worauf passiert denn Matrix direkt jetzt eigentlich?
Das ist ein selbstgeschriebenes Protokoll.
Das ist quasi wie Java von der Idee her,
dass du solche Standards hin und her schickst,
dass die bis zum Ende durch...
Also die Idee ist, dass die fertig,
ein Format ohne zigtausend XEPs.
Und du hast dieses eine fertige Format,
das implementiert jeder und dann schickst du diese Standards hin und her
und es sind alle Daten drin.
Von der Grundidee gibt es sich nicht groß zu Java.
Das ist glaube ich JSON-Blöcke,
sind statt XML.
Genau. Da fängt auch schon mal ein Problem an.
Das implementiert dann jeder,
macht niemand. Das hat bei XMPP schon vorzüglich
funktioniert.
Man kann doch wohl noch träumen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich war großer Fan von XMPP,
bis ich dann irgendwann
weg bin, weil ich konnte nie mit irgendjemandem
über OTR oder sonst was kommunizieren,
weil die haben wieder irgendeine andere Version von
Deep Purple verwendet oder waren auf
abstrusen Betriebssystemen wie iOS
unterwegs oder so.
Der Overlap von implementierten XEPs
war einfach nicht hinreichend.
Es ist wie so ein riesiges Venn-Diagram
und niemand ist in der Mitte.
Genau, und dann hat man immer mal geguckt,
wo gibt es denn irgendwie schöne Clients
für Leute, die jetzt einfach mal
so einen Client verwenden wollen.
Adium unter OSX ist ja ungepflegt
und meine liebste Commit-Message in Adium
ist, you can't even throw a stone
without finding a memory leak here.
Aber man muss es wieder nutzen,
weil Apple hat XMPP-Support aus Messages rausgepricht.
Es hätte vielleicht auch wieder
irgendjemand mal einfach einen Client schreiben können
oder sonst was.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es eine ganze Menge angefangene
XMPP-Clients mit so super
guten Features wie, wir machen keine Bilder, wir machen
viele, viele Sachen
nicht, weil wir sind hypersecure.
Und das sehe ich halt bei Matrix
auch einfach kommen, wenn die nicht mal auf die Kette kriegen,
einfach mal zu sagen, wir möchten mal hier
anfangen, Clients zu implementieren. Und ich sehe,
dass das das Matrix-Projekt selbst machen muss.
Und das fängt daran an,
dass sie zum Beispiel völlig
dokumentiert haben, wie eigentlich die Moderationsfeatures
sind. Ich habe ja vor kurzem Chats evaluieren
müssen, weil das Was-Projekt sich über Chats
gestritten hat und wir sind am Ende bei Discord gelandet.
Warum? Weil Discord wenigstens dokumentiert,
wie Moderation bei ihnen funktioniert.
Wir machen nur eine Moderation. Matrix macht das
nicht. Matrix schreibt irgendwo in Blogposts, das wäre
total toll, wenn sich da irgendjemand mal drum kümmern würde.
Aber das macht halt niemand.
Man findet irgendwo in der
API irgendwo Hinweise drauf, dass es
irgendwie was gibt. Und das
war es halt. Und
deswegen sehe ich einfach,
von technischen
Qualitäten von Matrix mal abgesehen,
einfach nicht, dass
dieses Ding momentan irgendwie zug kriegt.
Außer unter
in ganz bestimmten
Untergruppierungen. Und diese Untergruppierungen
sind noch nicht mal irgendwie eine Tech-Bubble,
sondern die Matrix-Bubble.
Es ist ein
Produkt aktuell, das stimmt schon.
Es tut mir im Herzen weh. Als ich gesehen habe, es will
irgendjemand nochmal XMPP in ordentlich machen,
habe ich mich sehr gefreut, weil ich wirklich XMPP
von der Idee her und
auch teilweise von der Funktionsweise
her gut finde.
Aber man hat einfach über die Jahre gesehen,
wie man sich da kaputt gemacht hat.
Und wenn man dann wieder sieht, irgendwie große
deutsche XMPP-Server, die eigentlich nicht mehr
machen als User-Beleidigungen,
können wir deinen User löschen?
Nachdem sie mal wieder einen Tag ausgefallen sind.
Von wegen,
du solltest eh einen anderen verwenden, weil wir sind ja
federated. Ja, ich fange jetzt aber auch hin
und ich hätte gerne einen Tag lang gechattet.
Okay, verstehe.
Und da sehe ich halt irgendwie ganz große Probleme und viele Leute, die viel rumnerden und auch gar nicht inkompetent rumnerden, aber sich leider nicht darum kümmern, wie sie diese Software am Ende auch richtig in die Hände von Usern bringen.
Und ich denke, das ist mal wichtig, weil wir brauchen, also keine Frage, wir brauchen das dringend.
Aber ein fundamentaler Unterschied zwischen Discord und Matrix ist,
wie ich das verstanden habe, Matrix ist, wir schreiben,
wir definieren mal ein Protokoll und machen eine Referenzimplementierung
und wir bitten euch darum, auch Implementierungen davon zu machen
und ein paar Leute machen es und dann bist du an der Stelle,
wo du bei XMPP bist.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein Protokoll und 35 Leute implementieren 36 Subsets des Protokolls.
Das ist halt der große Achillesferse von XMPP.
Discord ist ein Ding.
Das ist auch zentralisiert.
Discord ist quasi,
ich meine, ich habe Discord selber noch nie angeguckt, aber Discord ist
quasi wie Slack.
Slack nur anders.
Und dementsprechend gibt es da
keinen Wildwuchs, sondern was das
kann, das können alle überall, weil es gibt nur
das eine Teil. Richtig?
Ja, das stimmt so. Discord ist ein Service, so wie
Slack oder sonst was. Genau. Das hat
ein relativ sauber implementiert, ein kleines, war auch ein Elektron-App,
aber es funktioniert echt gut. Es ist
zentralisiert, es kommt aus der
Gaming-Szene, das kommt
zum Team-Speak-Ersatz, der
sich da entwickelt hat. Also mein
bevorzugtes Feature an Discord ist,
dass man einstellen kann, was man gerade spielt.
In dem Rust-Discord
so absurden Dingen spielt. Ich spiele Cargo.
Man nicht spielt die ganze Zeit System-D.
Das ist der beste Teil.
Okay.
Also
Gaming-Szene-Commerce hat
auch fantastische Moderation-Features.
Da brauchst du die halt. Ja, genau.
Die sind uns halt wichtig. Deswegen ist zum Beispiel auch Slack rausgeflogen, weil Slack hat richtig, richtig schlechte Moderation-Features. Die sind nämlich überhaupt nicht da und deswegen finde ich es unverantwortlich, dass Open-Source-Projekte in großem Stil Slack einsetzen.
Slack ist dafür gedacht, dass du es in deiner Firma einsetzt und da schmeißt du die Leute nicht raus, es sei denn, du schmeißt es aus der Firma raus.
Die Moderation von Slack ist HR. Du kriegst eine Abmahnung.
Das ist auch schön.
Ja, und insofern ist es aus der Sicht von Slack auch völlig normal, dass sie das nicht implementieren. Genauso hat Slack einfach auch ein Privatsphärenproblem, nämlich in dem Moment, in dem du dich beim Slack anmeldest, ist deine E-Mail-Adresse total öffentlich. Das macht in der Firma total Sinn.
Und deswegen ist Slack meiner Meinung nach da vom Ziel völlig inkompatibel, weil die einfach nicht für öffentliche Communities gebaut sind. Und es war ja früher auch so, dass man irgendwelche Bounce-Server brauchte, die einem eine automatische Invitation über die API gemacht haben und sonst was, damit man da überhaupt so etwas wie öffentliche Registrierung hinbekommen konnte.
Also da ist für mich der Punkt gekommen, wo ich auch wirklich sagen muss, ihr verwendet da ein Tool, das für diesen Einsatzzweck nicht gedacht ist. Discord ist für diesen Einsatzzweck gedacht und wir haben eine ganze Menge Sachen durchprobiert. Gitter ist kaputt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Gitter ist kaputt auf der Ebene, wo verschiedene Leute bei uns das Problem haben, dass sie den Channel nicht wechseln können im Interface, ohne die Seite einmal neu zu laden.
IAC-Cloud, wo so viele Leute drüber reden, setzt sich bei mir in der Firma ein, hat momentan seit Wochen Bugs, die dazu führen, dass neue Nachrichten nicht angezeigt werden, bis man den kleinen reloadet.
Okay, das habe ich sehr lange, sehr aktiv benutzt, war eigentlich immer recht glücklich, aber klar, solche Banken machen das natürlich total kaputt für den Use Case.
Genau und insofern, es gab da große Diskussionen darum, dass wir zu Discord gegangen sind und leider ist eine der ganz traurigen Sachen, die wir rausgefunden haben, allein die Ebene, es funktioniert und es hat Moderationsfeatures, erfüllt so gut wie gar nichts.
Das ist nicht traurig.
Man muss dazu natürlich auch sagen, das Was-Projekt, es gibt verschiedene Arbeitsgruppen, die noch im ERC sind und es bleiben. Es gibt welche, die verwenden andere. Also es ist den Arbeitsgruppen freigestellt. Es haben nur viele am Ende gesagt, oh mein Gott, das tue ich mir nicht an. Ich verwende Discord, das tut wenigstens.
Und das ist ein ganz trauriger Zustand. Und insofern sehe ich da auch richtig viel Gelegenheit. Also wenn mal jemand hingeht und sagt, wir nehmen jetzt zum Beispiel Matrix und wir bauen ein ordentliches Client-Set, das ordentlich modern ist, meinetwegen auch nativ und nicht eine Elektron-App, weil viele Leute ja keine Elektron-Apps haben wollen, auf iOS, Android, Mac, Windows, bitte auch Windows und Linux, zack.
Ich glaube, da ist richtig viel zu holen.
Und meinetwegen für Windows, Linux auch gerne mit GTK.
Also man kann GTK ja unter Windows verwenden
und sieht nicht total schlimm aus.
Da musst du ja immerhin nicht fünf Clients schreiben,
sondern nur drei.
Ja, den Mac, den GTK.
Unter Umständen solltest du halt mit LibMatrix anfangen,
denen sich einfach alle scheren
und ein natives Interface oben drüber
und vielleicht ein bisschen kleinere Brötchen backen.
Also da sehe ich zum Beispiel immer das Problem mit Federation.
Also die Leute fangen halt mit Federation an.
Das ist halt wichtig.
Wenn man das nicht direkt von Anfang an macht,
dann geht es halt im Nachhinein schlecht drüber zu bügeln.
Das gebe ich ja durchaus zu,
aber das Problem ist, momentan könnte man, glaube ich,
richtig, richtig, richtig viel holen,
indem man einfach mal sagt, wir lassen das Federation
Feature sein und sorgen erstmal dafür, dass es
einen ordentlichen Operator-Klein gibt,
der nicht im Betrieb unsicher ist.
Die meisten Matrix-Nutzer
nutzen ja den Matrix-Org-Homeserver
und sind somit recht
zentralisiert unterwegs.
Aber ich finde auch, die Client-Situation, die kommt halt
langsam. Die ist noch nicht da. Riot ist ein schlechter
Scherz. Es funktioniert. Es ist das
Einzige, was halt wirklich alle Features kann, aber es ist
mies. Aber
es gibt auch eine ganze Reihe anderer Clients,
die aktuell noch ein paar Subsets nur können
von den Features, die die Matrix unterstützt.
Aber sie existieren langsam. Es gibt
jetzt einen tollen neuen macOS-Client.
Seaglass heißt der, den probiere ich immer wieder aus.
Da passiert in letzter Zeit recht viel. Es gibt noch
einen, der heißt Neko. Ich glaube, das ist sogar eine GTK-App.
Da passieren Dinge. Und ich hoffe auch, dass sie
irgendwann toll werden. Aber wie wird
zum Beispiel dafür gesorgt, dass
die Leute, die dieses Ding implementieren, das auch
die nächsten 20 Jahre pflegen? Also das war jetzt
Das wäre das große Problem von Adium.
Im Prinzip ist Adium
hat viele Probleme.
Adium hat das ganze
Streaming und so weiter. Hätte man alles einfach besser
lassen können und so weiter. Aber das war halt
die Zeit, wo man gedacht hat, HTML, dann sind
Interfaces fertig. Also im Prinzip ist Adium
ja eine Elektron-App, außer dass sie sich Elektron
selbst gebaut haben.
Das trifft ganz gut die Herausforderung.
Mit allen Vor- und Nachteilen und vor allem damit,
dass es egal ist.
Aber irgendwann ist den Leuten
einfach die Luft ausgegangen. Also wie sorgen wir dafür?
Und so Messenger wie zum Beispiel Signal sorgen dafür, hey, wir haben hier eine Foundation, wir haben mal ein bisschen Geld.
Wir können da einfach Leute einstellen und dafür Geld...
Was macht Signal mit dem Geld?
Das fällt dabei rum, da kommt doch nichts mehr raus bei denen.
Die müssen das Betreiben.
Also das mal dahingestellt, aber die haben sich wenigstens darum gekümmert, dieses Problem zu lösen.
Bei Matrix sehe ich das noch nicht.
Wer steckt denn hinter Matrix? Also bei Discord ist das eine
kommerzielle Firma, soweit ich das verstehe?
Bei Discord steckt eine kommerzielle Firma dahinter.
Bei Matrix sind es Enthusiasten?
Also Discord muss man
haben relativ offen auf ihrer Webseite
stehen, können wir später mal verlinken, womit sie
eigentlich ihr Geld machen. Das machen sie
im Prinzip, indem sie genau dieses
Feature nutzen,
was spielst du gerade und so weiter
und so fort.
Und diese Metriken verkaufen sie an Spielefirmen.
Also, da gehen sie offen mit um.
Kann man für gut halten oder nicht.
Ich hoffe, dass System D
dann einfach demnächst von EA gekauft wird.
Das würde einfach super gut passen.
Wer spielt denn die ganze Zeit dieses System D?
Das muss ja krass sein.
Das wäre mal die Acquisition des Jahrhunderts.
EA Dice baut System D.
Du hast nicht auch das Problem,
dass es immer noch dieses Spiel Rust gibt,
wo Leute dann in dem Reddit
die ganze Zeit immer mal an dieses Spiel fragen?
Und das müsstest du einfach mal dort eintragen.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe gerade mal nachgeschaut.
Matrix.org, die wollen
Non-Profit werden, sind es aktuell noch nicht
und lassen sich finanzieren durch die Community selber.
Über Patreon, Liberate Pay,
diverse Bitcoins spenden und so weiter.
Ich finde ein ganz schwieriges Programm, weil damit kriegst du
nur mittelmäßig wenig Geld zusammen.
Die lassen sich ja jetzt auch noch mit durch die französische
Regierung finanzieren.
Das finde ich gut.
Das ist sehr cool, dass die da was aufbauen wollen.
Wie gesagt,
will den Effort gar nicht kleinreden. Ich habe nur
an vielen Stellen, ich denke,
sie haben ganz, ganz wichtige Punkte noch nicht besetzt.
Und das ist einfach,
in Chatsystemen gibt es Abuse, in federierten
Chatsystemen ist Abuse noch nicht gelöst.
Möchte ich auch einfach mal ganz direkt so sagen.
Moderation in federierten Systemen ist nicht gelöst.
Das ist auch ein schwieriges Problem, aber ja, absolut, ist nicht gelöst.
Ist ein schwieriges Problem.
Und es fehlen die Leute, die sich darüber auch einfach
Gedanken machen.
Ich finde es gut, dass es den Effort
gibt. Ich habe nur irgendwie so
meine Probleme mit und ich hätte einfach gerne, also
Ich hätte einfach gerne einen funktionierenden, guten Fos-Chat und ob der federiert ist, ist mir momentan egal. Also einfach, weil die alle so schlecht sind.
Nee, das stimmt schon. Das ist echt traurig. Es gibt echt kein gutes Protokoll und vor allem keine guten Clients, um irgendwas zu machen.
Und selbst die kommerziellen sind schlecht. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe jetzt natürlich noch nie einen Chat implementiert, aber ich weiß nicht, was zwischen, wir bauen das schnell als kleinen Example und wir bauen das als End-User-Produkt so schief gehen kann, dass das an so vielen Stellen so kaputt ist.
Habt ihr beim Evaluieren von diversen Protokollen auch mal Sulip ausprobiert? Bin ich jetzt vor kurzem drüber gestolpert, das sah recht witzig aus.
Sulip, ja,
Sulip hat genau dasselbe Problem.
Sulip hat, basiert ja auf einem
Uralt-Protokoll. Das weiß ich gar nicht, was die
machen. Aus irgendeiner Uni.
Z-U-L-I-P schreibt sich das Ganze übrigens.
Ich finde Sulip
cool, weil Sulip
genau, sulipchat.com
Weil Sulipchat
so ein bisschen anders denkt. Ich setze
Sulip auch an verschiedenen Stellen privat ein,
aber auch genau an dieser Stelle, Moderation
ist überhaupt nicht angedacht.
und wird von dem Unterprotokoll auch schlecht erforscht.
Vielleicht mal kurz dazu Klärung, was Sulib als Möglichkeit bietet.
Man kann in Sulib in jedem, in sogenannten Streams immer gleich noch Topics eröffnen.
Also man kann sagen, ich möchte jetzt über dieses GitHub-Issue reden
und dann können Leute direkt darauf reagieren.
Also es ist eigentlich immer threaded.
Wie Slacks, Threadbus ist alles in Threads passiert.
Genau.
Das ist wirklich schön.
Das eignet sich vom User-Interface auch richtig gut für Langnachrichten.
Deswegen mag ich es sehr gerne.
Wie es heißt, es ist alles Thread-basiert.
Bei Slack kann ich aus jeder Nachricht einen Thread starten.
Ja, nee, aber es gibt per Default nur Threads.
Du hast keine Nachrichten, die global in dem Channel hängen,
sondern alles hängt in irgendeinem Thread.
Du kannst natürlich dann auch einen Main-Thread haben, wenn du möchtest.
Das heißt, wenn ich den Channel betrete und sage Hi,
dann ist das bereits ein Thread?
Du schreibst nicht Hi, du startest ein Thread mit deinem Thema.
Ach so, okay.
Dann ist das also mehr ein bisschen forummäßig quasi.
Du kannst natürlich auch hingehen, du kannst
einen Ongoing Threat haben,
zum Beispiel in deinem General Channel,
der heißt Hello, den gibt es auch häufig
und dann kannst du
halt an den Hello,
in das Hello-Topic natürlich immer
deine Vorstellung dranhängen und so weiter und so fort.
Ich finde es vom Interface
sehr angenehm, weil es auch wirklich
das Konzept-Chat neu
denkt.
Wie gesagt,
Moderation ist so gut wie unmöglich
du kannst also keine öffentliche Instanz betreiben
aber eigentlich wenn man drüber nachdenkt
jetzt haben wir die ganze Zeit nur über Features
geredet, wir gehen jetzt davon aus
dass die grundlegenden technischen Sachen bei den Dinger dann
immer gelöst sind, viele basieren einfach
wahrscheinlich drunter trotzdem nur auf XMPP
bloß das ist irgendwie anders nach oben
die meisten klassischen proprietären
Chatlösungen haben ja mit XMPP angefangen
das Facebook Chat, Google Chat, WhatsApp
das ist ja alles Anfangs mal XMPP gewesen
bis sie dann irgendwann merkten
wir migrieren weg, weil wir kommen mit XMPP nicht mehr klar
Für die Leute in Hinterpreis-Umgebung empfehle ich Cisco XMPP.
Was ist das für ein esoterischer?
Cisco Jabber heißt das dann.
Cisco Jabber, ja.
Aber das ist doch schon noch Jabber?
Das ist so ein Jabber mit einem Cisco-Client und so bedient es sich so.
Ah, okay, also gar nicht.
Aber funktioniert. Kann halt kein OTR.
Insofern kann man sich über den schlechten OTR-Support nicht beschweren.
Also immerhin kriegt man keinen Schrott.
Aber es ist halt unverschlüsselt.
Bei XMPP ist auch so ein bisschen,
wenn man über OTR redet,
die haben halt immer die Einführung.
Und da würde ich gerne wissen, wie Matrix das lösen möchte.
Was machen sie?
Also wie bringen sie dieses
Protokoll
weiter irgendwann?
Bei Jabba hat man es ja mit
O-Memo gesehen.
Da gab es irgendwann was, aber das hat
irgendjemand dann der Daniel Kulsch
selber gemacht, weil
der Einzige war, der gemeint hat, wir brauchen
das jetzt? Ich power das jetzt durch alleine.
Aber was er richtig durchgesetzt hat,
siehst du nicht. Manche Kleinskünz.
Manche Kleinskünz. Genau, was dann halt eben
zu dem Problem führt. Hauptsächlich die,
die er selbst gepatcht hat.
Ja, und das führt dann zu dem Problem, dass halt, ich
verwende Jabba keine Aussage mehr ist, sondern
ich verwende Jabba mit folgendem Klein und dann
brauchst du noch folgendem Klein und dann funktioniert das halt
irgendwie und so. Ich hab neulich mal wieder Psy ausgegraben
und konnte niemanden anschreiben, weil Psy kein Omeo
konnte. Mein Opa hat mich per Jabba angeschrieben.
Ach nee, ich mein WhatsApp, aber ist ja auch bloß
eigenproprietärer Jabba-Standard, den wieder
hat. Nee, ähm,
ja, Jabba ist halt schwierig.
Das stimmt schon. Es gibt halt einen guten Jabba-Client
und das war's in das Conversations für Android.
Ich hab vor kurzem einen ganz interessanten Blogpost gelesen,
der mir
auf diese Situation irgendwie ein bisschen passte.
Das hat
der Autor, seinen Namen
hab ich vergessen, von,
na, wie hieß dieser,
äh,
dieser Compositor, Compets,
genau, das Ding mit dem Würfel.
Der hat einen Artikel darüber geschrieben,
warum er Compets nicht auf Wayland portiert wird.
Und zwar mit der Begründung,
dass
grundsätzlich alles, was, also
dass Compets natürlich vieles kann und die
meisten Leute denken, Compets ist das Ding mit dem Würfel.
Aber an sich ist das erstmal
ein generischer Compositor und er hat
gesagt, diesen Würfel zu portieren auf Wayland,
dann nehmt ihr euch einen Compositor und macht einen Würfel rein,
das ist nicht schwer.
Dann sagt er, er möchte aber nicht,
er möchte nicht, dass es einen weiteren Compositor
für Wayland gibt, weil es
gibt schon genügend.
es gibt halt Weston und es gibt noch
ein, zwei andere und das Problem
das er sieht ist, dass alle Leute
immer ihren eigenen Compositor schreiben müssen
möchten und er eigentlich sieht
dass die Leute eigentlich bei bestehenden weiter
mitarbeiten sollten und er hat diesen schönen Satz fallen
lassen, das Problem an der Open Source Community
ist, sie erfinden nicht nur das Rad neu
sondern das Auto da dran gleich noch mit
und das ist so das Gefühl, das ich bei XMPP
halt habe, also viele Leute haben so gedacht
ich schreibe jetzt mal endlich den XMPP-Client
den ich haben wollte, statt dass ich irgendwie Gruppen gefunden habe
Das Problem haben wir übrigens in der RAS-Community an verschiedenen Stellen auch.
Deswegen haben wir so viele Webfamworks und alles ein Mist.
Dass sich nicht mal Gruppen finden und sagen,
wir wollen jetzt einfach mal den super Satz Matrix-Clients schreiben.
Koste es, was es wolle.
Unter anderem auch, das ist kein Fun-Projekt.
Also wenn ich das ernst nehme, dann ist das kein Fun-Projekt.
Das ist aber eine grundlegende Kritik, die seit Jahren an jeder Linux-Distro geübt wird.
Natürlich.
Oh, ist ja schön, dass ihr eine neue Linux-Distro gemacht habt.
Warum helft ihr nicht den anderen Linux-Distros aus?
Die werden auch bloß von drei Leuten entwickelt.
Helft denen doch mal aus.
Die haben grundlegende Probleme, wo sie Hilfe brauchen.
Ich meine, ich finde es sehr gut, dass Leute das zum Spaß machen.
Also die Gelegenheit, dass man einfach mal sagen kann,
ich baue mir mal meine Linux-Distros selbst, ist natürlich was ganz Mächtiges.
Aber
da ist immer die Frage,
baue ich das, damit das andere Leute
verwenden sollen? Dann muss ich damit im anderen Anspruch
rangehen, als wenn ich sage, baue ich das
mit einem
Freundeskreis, damit wir
irgendwie hier mal unser eigenes Linux gebaut haben.
Ich habe mit Gentoo Stage 1
Linux angefangen.
Völlig sinnfreies Ding, aber damit habe ich
Linux gelernt von Basis auf.
Ja, gerade wenn es darum geht,
Enterprise, äh Quatsch, gerade wenn es
darum geht, Infrastruktur zu schaffen,
Und ein gleichmäßig gut für alle Plattformen funktionierendes Chat-Protokoll oder Messaging-Protokoll mit Clients und Backend ist eine Sache und Linux-Instituts sind eine andere Sache.
Also ich glaube, wenn wir sowas wie das Debian-Projekt, was seit Jahren an einem Projekt gemeinsam an einem Strang zieht und kontinuierlich Qualität liefert, nicht hätten, dann wäre auch, glaube ich, Linux nie soweit gewesen.
Und sowas wie das bräuchte man quasi dementsprechend für andere Infrastrukturprojekte auch.
Deswegen habe ich ja nach Finanzierung gefragt.
Also das Problem, das ich sehe, ist,
es rein motivationsabhängig zu machen.
Das ist ziemlich schwierig für viele Dinge.
Aber in dem Moment, wo ich sagen kann,
wir haben übrigens 50 Millionen auf der Bank, wie Signal,
die dann einfach sagen...
50 Millionen.
50 Millionen waren es die da irgendwie...
Oder 50, ja.
Genau.
Gut, da könnte man tatsächlich noch ein bisschen mehr Leute mit anstellen.
Genau. Und da kann man auch einfach mal sagen,
das machen die Leute einfach
9 to 5 und natürlich
sollten die motiviert sein, aber die müssen
nicht so motiviert sein, dass sie statt
abends in die Kneipe gehen, zu Hause Single bauen.
Das ist einfach eine ganz andere
Art von Motivation.
Das ist richtig.
Deswegen ist es mir so wichtig, dass Leute, die solche Projekte
bauen, unter Umständen ihren Lebensunterhalt damit verdienen können.
Und deswegen
ist halt so,
Matrix ist jetzt schon eine ganze Weile unterwegs.
Warum ist diese Foundation noch nicht gegründet?
Weil
da kommt der andere Punkt, Leute machen
nicht aus Bock Buchhaltung.
Das könnte man vielleicht auch als
As-a-Service anbieten.
Ja, ich meine, man könnte natürlich,
das machen ja im Prinzip die Linux Foundation und die
FSF und was weiß ich sonst.
Die Apache, wir nehmen das bei uns rein.
Die Apache Foundation
aber zum Beispiel darf keine Developer bezahlen.
bei den Instituten. Die dürfen nur
Info-Druck.
Krass.
Wir driften da ab.
Wir waren gerade bei Signal. Habt ihr diesen
I-Don't-Trust-Signal-Blog-Post gelesen?
Na klar.
Toller Post. Also ich mochte ihn, aber ich habe
persönlich viele Probleme mit Signal.
Aber der geht ja
vor allem drauf ab, dass
das Signal nicht über F-Dot
verfügbar ist. Signiert und
nicht ohne Google-Services.
Und das macht Signal halt nicht, aus Gründen, die keiner nachvollziehen kann.
Signal kriegst du nur über den Google Play Store mit Google Crapware drin, Spyware.
Oder du kriegst direkt das APK-Download, überhaupt nicht verifizient ohne Updates.
Stand also drin, ich hätte das noch nicht verstanden, dass es das doch über Afterworld gibt.
Nee, eben nicht über Afterworld, das ist ja das Problem.
Genau, und das kann Moxie bzw. die Open-Wars-Passistenz gut begründen.
Und das ist halt das, was der kritisiert an Signal.
Und ich finde es absolut gerechtfertigt, das zu kritisieren.
weil das geht eigentlich nicht für Software,
die sich auf die Flaggen schreibt,
ich will der sicherste Messenger überhaupt sein,
nutze mich, wenn du Angst vor Nation-State,
vor Nation-Aktives hast.
Sagen sie das?
Signal wird auch an allen Ecken dafür empfohlen,
von Edward Snowden, von Moxie, von allen möglichen Leuten.
Das behaupten die das von sich selber,
weil, wie ich das verstanden hatte,
hat Signal oder Moxie vor irgendeiner Zeit,
kurz bevor sie, oder nachdem sie,
das Axolotl-Protokoll in WhatsApp mit eingebaut hat,
gesagt, so jetzt eigentlich, jetzt haben wir eine Baseline
geschaffen, in WhatsApp ist unser
Protokoll jetzt drin, jetzt können wir
eigentlich aufhören, weil eigentlich wollten wir nicht hier
das geilste Ding bauen, sondern
vornehmlich einfach die Baseline ein bisschen
anheben von Krypto. Cool.
Das ist ja überhaupt kein Ziel.
Also ein gutes Ziel.
Ist quasi als Referenzimplementierung
gedacht gewesen und
dass Leute jetzt sagen, nehmt das,
wenn ihr irgendwie um euer Leben fürchtet,
ist ein bisschen krass.
Das würde ich nicht, was ich mitbekommen habe,
Vielleicht habe ich da ein leicht gedrehtes
Bild davon.
Also zumindest bei diesem Blogpost kann ich
kritisieren, dass der so ein bisschen
an der Verschwörungskiste zieht,
weil tatsächlich Moxy irgendwelche Unterstellungen
macht, dass er irgendwelche Hintergedanken
dabei hat, dass er es nicht auf F2 tut.
Also das ist auch mein Problem mit diesem
Blogpost. Er zieht es im Prinzip
direkt an diesem...
Aber wenn ich Sorgen
um die NSA habe, dann
und dann ist das irgendwie...
Dann ist das unmoralisch, das zu machen und er sagt auch
wo zwischendrin
das Abstriche bei Security einfach nicht
gehen, auch wenn es
auch wenn es um Usability geht
und auch da wieder habe ich ein bisschen
die Sicht, das Problem ist
Security
an der Stelle
viele Leute haben schlicht und einfach
kein Problem damit das Geheimdienste unter Umständen
mitlesen können, weil das für sie keine Gefahr ist
die sie sehen. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Problem
aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema
das ist auch eine Sicht, die ich
die ich völlig okay finde
Es gibt Leute, die können die begründen und
viele Leute
denken auch gar nicht in diesen Sphären.
Aber es gibt ja durchaus Fälle
von Lebenspartner,
die es mit unter
Umständen oder sonst was, das kann durchaus gefährlich
werden und da ist Signal natürlich eine bedeutende
Verbesserung zu dem, was wir haben. Also
Leute, die die E-Mails ihrer Partner lesen, gibt's
alle naselang.
Obwohl davor Signal jetzt nicht unbedingt
gut schützt. Also du kannst
das locken und auf dem Gerät
verschlüsseln, aber...
naja, Einbrüche
in E-Mail-Konten und so weiter
und so fort, hat man schon von vielem gehört.
Achso, na gut, okay.
Ich möchte
noch dazu geben, mit krimineller Energie.
Und das hört man alle Nase lang.
Und das ist zum Beispiel ein Threatmodel, das mir in dieser
Szene einfach viel zu selten
mitgenommen wird.
Es geht immer bloß um die NSA quasi.
Genau, und das hatte ich
so den Eindruck, er zieht es halt so über,
aber ich muss hier gleich mit State Actor
anfangen und
das
macht mir so ein bisschen Sorgen bei den
Sphären, in denen er denkt.
Ob man das sich persönlich als Problem sieht oder nicht,
ob da jetzt der State Actor
ein Problem für mich darstellt oder nicht,
sind wir da hingestellt, aber die Tatsache,
dass das halt ein Problem für Menschen
sein kann, ist es dann gerechtfertigt,
so eine Lösung zu empfehlen?
Das hebt halt nur
das Level leicht an.
Das glaube ich halt deswegen nicht.
Deswegen frage ich mich, ob die
fehlen, wenn ihr
Whistleblower seid und um euer Leben
fürchtet, dann nehmt Signal. Das habe ich glaube ich
zumindest bei Snowden gar nicht rausgehört.
Die Aussage war,
es gibt einen allgemeinen
Launchangriff und alle Nachrichten
im Internet werden mitgelesen. Also wäre es gut, wenn
jeder grundsätzlich überall verschlüsselt.
Einfach damit da eine Baseline
an Sicherheit geschaffen wird. Und ich habe
auch Aussagen von Moxie
rausgehört, dass sie quasi
Mehrwert auf
allgemeine Verfügbarkeit und
Usability gelegt haben, einfach damit es mehr Leute
benutzen, die sich keine Gedanken um Security
machen, damit einfach eine Baseline da ist
von verschlüsselter Kommunikation, selbst
wenn es nicht wichtig ist, dass in dieser Situation
verschlüsselt wird. Ich finde das gefährlich.
Jemand, der hingeht und sagt,
ich habe wirklich
Sachen, wo ich mich vor State-Aktoren
verstecken muss,
die sollten dann
eventuell zu anderen Lösungen
greifen und nicht unbedingt.
Natürlich hat Signal auf ihrer Webseite hier
Trotzki und
andere Leute als Beispiel
aufgenommen. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen krass.
Ich höre als Empfehlung für solche Leute immer nur Signal. Und Signal hat halt
zentralisierte Server, die in den USA stehen,
die jederzeit das Problem haben, wir könnten das
jemand an der Tür klopfen und sagen, wir hätten gerne wieder alle Logs.
Aber dann ist genau diese Sorte Kommunikation,
die er in diesem Blockboss fährt, halt einfach problematisch.
Weil er sich nicht darauf, also
er umreißt das Problem einfach nicht stark genug.
Wenn er sagen würde, Signal
ist eine Scheiß-App für solche Einsatzzwecke,
wäre ich sofort dabei.
Habe ich überhaupt kein Problem und alle diese Argumente
sind super gültig. Das Problem ist nur,
dass man immer wieder annimmt
ich habe
es wird wenig Kommunikation betrieben, die
direkt sagt
du bist in einem Land, in dem dich wahrscheinlich
der Geheimdienst überwachen wird
und festnehmen
dann hast du
wo sind die Blogposts
es gibt Blogposts, die sich darum kümmern
wie machst du das
aber es gibt wenig Blogposts, die sagen
ich möchte
eine halbwegs ordentliche
Security als
Alltagsprodukt.
Ja, als Alltagsprodukt.
Das ist gut.
Dass man dringend mal auftrennen muss,
dass unter Umständen es in diesem Bereich halt eben
Alltagsprodukte gibt und nicht Alltagsprodukte.
Also wenn du jetzt
wirklich von
Whistleblowern ausgehst
in Nordkorea, dann würde ich
tatsächlich auch wirklich nicht unbedingt
selbst von Signal ausgehen,
weil du zum Beispiel
davon ausgehen kannst, okay,
dann ist es egal, ob du
wirklich lesen kannst, was die schicken,
dann reicht es, wenn du rauskriegst, dass die schicken.
Dann sind sie bereits identifizierbar
und es ist ja egal, dass du
nicht lesen kannst, was die geschrieben haben, das reicht schon
für einen grundlegenden Verdacht. Dafür gibt es dann so
Sachen, die jetzt natürlich nicht ausgereift
sind, wie dieses Ricochet,
was über das
BitTorrent-Netzwerk
kommuniziert. Ja, Quatsch.
Was über das Torrent-Netzwerk kommuniziert, wo quasi
deine Adresse
eine Tor-Adresse
ist.
Wenn es im Thema Alltagsprodukte
geht, klar,
reden wir auf einer anderen Ebene weiter, dass wir
einfach den Power einfach heben wollen für
den Alltagsnutzer. Aber warum kann SignSign
nicht so einen einfachen Schritt gehen, wie
Desktop-Client rausbringen, der funktioniert,
die App auf F-Doll publishen, damit sie
andere Nutzer auch nutzen können, die nicht noch zusätzlich
von Google ausspioniert werden wollen. Warum
machen die so einen Mist?
Also Desktop-Client rausbringen, haben sie funktioniert,
ist... Ja, das sagst du.
Okay, das sag ich, ja.
Das ist halt...
Wer baut heutzutage
noch gerne Desktop-Anwendungen?
Deswegen greifen alle zu Elektronen.
Das ist halt so. Ja gut, aber man muss
an der Stelle durchaus sagen,
dadurch, dass Elektron so viele Dependencies hat,
ist natürlich da durchaus ein
Auditierungsproblem da. Ja, das stimmt.
Also, ganz abgesehen davon, dass
Elektron-Apps, gerade vor kurzem haben sie wieder
irgendeine...
Welche waren denn das? Also es gab eine
Schwachstelle in Elektron, die dazu geführt hat, dass ich dir
eine Nachricht über Signal auf deinen Desktop-Signal
schicken konnte, die dann in dem Elektron ausgeführt wurde.
Ja, das war das eine.
Super.
Vor kurzem hat jemand in einer anderen Elektron-App,
ich glaube, es war irgendeiner von Google, die Möglichkeit
gefunden, diese App halt irgendwie eine beliebige
Webseite laden zu lassen.
Und dann kannst du natürlich wieder eine Webseite ausliefern,
die genauso aussieht wie das Programm selbst.
Und dadurch, dass du keine Adressleiste mehr hast,
siehst du das grüne
Schloss oben nicht.
Genau, du lieferst halt
also das ist durchaus der Vorteil
an Desktop-Apps an dieser Stelle.
Die kommen halt nicht unbedingt
gleich mit einer kompletten
dynamischen Laufzeitumgebung.
Eingeschränkt. Also
Kokoa ist an sich auch wieder eine dynamische Laufzeitumgebung.
Aber
insofern das Argument
kann ich durchaus nachvollziehen.
aber da ist man auch wieder an dem Problem
Desktop-Umgebungen
haben rausgefunden, dass sie
ihre Applikationen möglichst schlecht portierbar machen wollen
Es ist bei allen Herstellern so, dass die
Desktop-Umgebungen werden von Leuten gebaut
Das ist ja nicht das Ziel davon, das ist ja passiert und das ist doof, dass wir diese Situation haben
aber das war glaube ich nicht das Ziel explizit
Das ist einfach historisch so gewachsen
Ich habe das Toolkit für mein Betriebssystem
gebaut.
Das Toolkit ist halt untereinander echt scheiße funktionieren
und man kann es nicht finden, außer man geht jetzt
den Weg des Webs.
Bei Microsoft haben sie sich halt nie gefragt,
ob sie mit dem Framework auch eine Anwendung
für Mac oder für Linux machen.
Microsoft geht ja andersrum. Die schauen ja, dass sie
Frameworks hinkriegen, die einfach mal
dass sie einen Schirm hinlegen,
dass du die UI-Kit-APIs von
MacOS, von Coco ansprechen kannst auf Windows
und das dann eben drunter legen.
Also ich habe das fertig gewonnen, das Projekt weiß ich gar nicht,
aber da haben sie lange dran gearbeitet.
Das fand ich witzig von der Idee her,
dass, Mist, niemand baut bei uns Software.
Das können wir den Leuten helfen. Ja, wir machen es für sie.
Na gut, ich meine, am Ende ist natürlich auch das Bedienmodell
von den ganzen Motivsystemen nicht umsonst unterschiedlich.
Ja klar.
Und da hat sich, glaube ich,
auch wenig Praxis drum gefunden.
Elektron ist da halt so ein bisschen der Weg raus.
Auf die Kosten,
dass sich halt alles überall gleich schlechter
ändert.
und überall gleich unsicher ist.
Nee.
Aber was mich halt an Signal
jetzt nochmal kurz stört, was er hier in dem Blogpost
anspricht, ist, dass die
Argumentation funktioniert halt irgendwo nicht.
Wenn Leute schon seit Jahren vorschlagen,
dass Open Whisper Systems Signal doch bitte mal
auf F2 publischen sollen und Moxi
daherkommt und das schon seit Jahren
blockiert mit, aber es gibt doch kein Upgrade-Channel
und auf F2 haben wir
kein App-Scanning, das ist doch, das
garantiert unsere Sicherheit und
Signal irgendwann daherkommt und sagt,
wir müssen vielleicht mal was machen und eine APK direkt
auf die Webseite legt, die erst recht kein
Upgrade-Channel hat. F-Dol hat einen Upgrade-Channel mit signierten
Updates. Google's Play Store
hat App-Scanning, aber das hilft nicht gegen
ziemlich viel Mehrweber, die da rumliegt. F-Dol
wird durch Menschen gecheckt. Da liegt
echt, soweit ich weiß, wenig
Schrott rum. Bedeutet weniger Schrott
als im Play Store. Das ist halt einfach keine
Argumentation, die von Seiten Open Whisper Systems funktioniert.
Und ich verstehe das nicht. Und ich finde es witzig,
dass er in der Hinsicht dann hingeht, wie er schon meint,
und so ein bisschen sehr Richtung Verschwörungstheorie geht.
Aber was bleibt denn grob anderes übrig, wenn die Argumentation so scheiße ist und er überhaupt nichts mehr rüberkommt von Open-West-Persistent?
Na gut, er hätte sich einfach auf die Argumentation beschränken können.
Also er zieht es auf als, ich mag Sigl nicht und das ist schon immer klar, natürlich mag er sich nur nicht, die Aussage will ich ihm nicht nehmen, aber man hätte es halt bedeuten, mehr zusammenziehen können.
Das Argument, warum Sigl nicht im F-Dort ist, ist einfach Schrott.
Ja, das ist es halt klar.
Das gebe ich ihm auch gerne.
und es ist, ich
kenne ja, ich habe vor kurzem mich mal länger
unterhalten mit jemandem, der
Add-on Screening bei Mozilla macht
ich bin relativ beeindruckt
also ich hatte vor kurzem die große Freude
Leute von Mozilla zu schulen
die Code Review machen
und seitdem glaube ich wieder so ein bisschen mehr
an persönliches Review
seitdem sind meine Folien auch geputzt
Also die haben Fehler
Ich habe meinen Waskurs schon 10 Mal
gegeben und da sind Fehler
drin, es sind nie jemandem aufgefallen und plötzlich
hat man da jemanden, der ist schon in dem Moment
nicht mehr die Folie aufsetzt
Das ist cool
Das funktioniert so?
Oh, nein
Das ist cool, das ist ziemlich cool
Aber ist das so krachbar
Wie funktioniert das so?
Wie ist der Prozess da?
Der Prozess des Elon-Squennings?
Das ist wirklich manuell
und es wird gelesen, was diese Addons machen.
Es wird geschaut, was für APIs
sie ansprechen. Das ist cool.
Die haben nicht besonders
viel Zeit pro Addon, aber die
entsprechenden Leute haben wohl
ein sehr geschultes Auge.
Wie gesagt,
das war eine kurze Unterhaltung, also unter Umständen.
Ich kann euch mal einen Kontakt geben.
Nicht der Gast.
Sitzt hier
in Berlin, aber
der Prozess ist manuell und er hat
gesagt, das ist so ein bisschen wie, wenn man halt
in einer anderen Sache
Fachkenntnis hat, scrollt man mal so durch
Code und denkt sich so, warte mal, das sieht doch
fishy aus.
Die fangen dabei wohl relativ viel, weil
natürlich auch viel versucht wird, über Addons Daten
auszuleiten und so weiter
und so fort. Hat sich auch schon einiges verbessert,
seitdem diese Web-Extension-API
standardisiert ist, siehst du jetzt bei Addons,
die da auf Firefox installiert ist, auch endlich kann auf das
zugreifen, kann auf das zugreifen. Nice, das ist cool.
Also es gibt viele,
viele Gründe für diese Web-Extension-API und
Davon war wirklich halt auch Sicherheit.
Vorher konntest du halt wirklich alles, was in Firefox
war, rausgraben.
Und was ja Firefox auch
komplett kaputt gemacht hat. Das ist natürlich total schade
für Leute, die wirklich fundamental ihren Bausam
mit einem Add-on umbauen wollten, dass das jetzt nicht mehr geht.
Aber das war einfach
nicht so gegangen.
Also man hat ja irgendwie
ein Konzept aus den 90ern.
In den 90ern hat man ja wohl gedacht, dass es gut
Leuten einfach hier, die werden
schon kein Schindluder treiben.
Das ist nicht krass, da wusste ich eigentlich, dass da so viel Arbeit
tatsächlich dahinter steckt,
in dem oftmals so als sicher getautet
Apple App Store passiert,
das sind sehr lächerliche Prozesse, die da
davor laufen. Ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass die
so unterschiedlich sind, oder?
Also das ist schon manuell, aber was die machen,
ist lächerlich.
Ja klar, das Volumen ist ganz anders.
Keine Frage. Aber es ist trotzdem,
also da möchte ich eigentlich
nicht drüber randen, weil es einfach nur Schrott ist, was bei Apple da passiert,
aber im Vergleich zu Google
Nein, aber
krass, ich wusste echt nicht, dass da wirklich Leute sind,
die den Code anschauen. Das finde ich cool, das finde ich großartig.
Und na gut, bei Apple
lädst du halt deine geschriebenen Applikationen
und nicht dein Code, insofern wenn die dann auch andere Sachen
prüfen. Die prüfen trotzdem darauf,
an welche APIs du bindest und so weiter und so fort.
Püppis. Oh, da habe ich auch.
Ich bin ja in dem Swift Slack
mit aktiv und da haben wir jetzt
vor kurzem Slack.
Jemanden gehabt, der hat eine Xcode Extension
gebaut, also eine Erweiterung für Apples
IDE. Und Apple hat,
früher gab es Xcode Extensions
als inoffizielles
Produkt, also die haben einfach existiert.
Das waren quasi Extensions, die sich in die laufende Anwendung
quasi reingeladen haben und irgendwas getan haben.
Das lief auch ganz toll, da gab es viele tolle Sachen
und wir waren alle sehr glücklich.
Und dann kam Apple
daher und meinte, Xcode ist jetzt aber nicht mehr
secure, wir können es sich garantieren.
Und wir machen das mal komplett dicht und das System checkt jetzt
die Integrity von Xcode und alles wird
unterbunden, du kannst nie mehr in den laufenden Prozess reinhaken.
Da gab es ja tatsächlich Angriffe durch Extensions.
Dieses Xcode Ghost gab es da noch
mit diesem gehackten Xcode, wo deine
Applikation beim Bauen irgendwelche
Backdoors mit reingebaut hast, beziehungsweise deine Credentials
irgendwie hoch hingeschoben hast.
Das ist schon sehr, sehr sinnvoll, das abzusichern.
Zum Teil, ja. Das Problem war
da halt, dass sie halt diese Extensions komplett zerstört
haben. Die gab es halt nicht mehr. Und dann kam Apple daher mit Xcode 8
und sagte, hey, wir haben jetzt eine tolle neue Extension-API
bei Extensions. Und ihr habt da drauf
geschaut und habt gemerkt, dass du damit überhaupt nichts machen kannst.
Und jetzt
kommen Leute daher und bauen immer mehr Extensions. Die APIs
wurde ein bisschen erweitert. Mittlerweile kann man sogar ein paar mehr Sachen
machen. Das ist immer noch lachhaft im Vergleich zu was früher
ging. Logisch, wenn man das jetzt offizielle APIs
hat, ist das was anderes. Das Witzige
an dem Prozess ist halt nur, wenn du eine Xcode-Exemption
baust und die hochlädst,
dann linkt das irgendwelche internen APIs mit rein
oder interne Frameworks,
was verständlich ist, wenn das der Prozess so möchte.
Das Witzige ist, sobald die
bei iTunes Connect hochgeladen wird, also wo du die App
hochlädst, damit sie für den App-Stalk gepublished wird, checkt dieser
Scanner da, diese internen Framework nicht,
dass das eine Sache ist.
Sieht, du sprichst irgendwelche internen APIs an, es direkt gefl
rejected. Achso, dann haben sie einfach in ihrem Checkprozess.
Ja, aber es hat anscheinend nie jemand diesen Prozess durchgespielt,
oder was? Das heißt, es hat noch jemanden
eine Extension veröffentlicht.
Ja, aber intern von Apple, wenn jede
Exxon-Exxon dagegen redet und du immer dem Reviewer manuell
sagen musst, hey, wenn da übrigens dieser Fehler kommt,
das ist nicht meine Schuld, das macht der Prozess
so und das solltet ihr besser wissen, das ist doch lächerlich.
Ja, das passiert ein paar Mal danach.
Anscheinend ja nicht, das ist seit Jahren,
wir sind bei Exxon-10 aktuell,
Exxon-8 gibt es Exxon-Exxonions.
Wenn wir mit den Apps verwerben können,
vielleicht ist das auch erst seit einem Jahr so, aber...
Was man Apple
dass sie ja schon einen sehr starken Consumer-Fokus haben.
Also,
sobald man dann
so in den Entwicklungsbereich
kommt, wird es dann so ein bisschen haarig.
Ich fand es einfach ein witziges Detail, dass das halt
anscheinend in dieser Prozesse
nie durchlaufen wurde von irgendjemandem, der
keine HQA macht, der den Prozess
mitentwickelt und man probiert auch, schaut, ob es überhaupt funktioniert.
Das wirkt ein bisschen komisch.
Diese Leute haben unter dem Stellen auch einfach Sonderrechte.
Das kann natürlich gut sein. Ach klar, für mich klappt
das natürlich. Es geht nur für
für Apple interne Extensions.
Genau.
Ich meine, interne Apps dürfen ja
interne APIs ansprechen,
deswegen sind sie ja da.
Insofern kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das
an dieser Stelle im Prozess hakt.
Ja.
Da gab es ja auch das Witzige.
Viele Mac-Apps haben ja über die letzten Jahre
hinweg irgendeinen Blogpost groß veröffentlicht.
Ja, warum wir den Mac-Apps nur verlassen?
Weil sie einfach nicht damit klarkommen, mit den
Entitlements, die du da bekommst, beziehungsweise mit den
Rechten und aus der Sandbox,
die halt ein bisschen eng zu sein scheinen,
beziehungsweise dem, was du teilweise machen musst als App,
das geht halt einfach nicht, um die App im App Store zu publishen,
was die Apps machen wollen.
Und haben das groß immer als Blogpost veröffentlicht
und anscheinend das Apple gegen den Strich,
aber die waren halt unglücklich damit,
dass Leute nicht im Mac App Store publishen,
weil das Plattform für den Endnutzer halt generell sehr praktisch ist.
Und deswegen sind jetzt auch mit dem zuletzten WWDC im Juni,
kam wohl raus, dass viele Apps jetzt wieder im Mac App Store verfügbar sind.
Die Frage ist bloß allerdings am Beispiel Transmit zum Beispiel,
Das ist unter anderem ein SFTP
und diverse andere Protokolle.
Das ist mit der Kummierende, oder?
Nee, das ist Cyberduck.
Von Panic, einem sehr bekannten
Apple-Entwicklungsstudio, die es seit vielen, vielen Jahren gibt.
Die machen super schön zu bedienen.
S3-Client dran und so.
Ja, Transparenz ist eine tolle App.
Und die Frage war halt, wie zum Teufel geht das jetzt wieder im Mac App Store?
Und das hat sich immer noch nicht geklärt.
Panic hat bisher noch nichts gesagt, aber anscheinend ist jetzt auf Twitter rumgekommen,
dass diese Apps tatsächlich von Apple
Sonderentitlements bekommen haben, die auch nur diese Apps haben,
damit die im Mac App Store funktionieren.
Das ist doch auch kein Prozess. Das ist doch doof.
Das ist sehr ärgerlich.
Sie sind einfach systemkritisch.
Ja klar, aber es ist natürlich...
Die können halt dann auch nicht ersetzt werden,
weil du kannst halt kein Konkurrenzprodukt bauen
und zu Apple gehen und sagen,
wo willst du denn zu Apple hingehen?
Du kannst dich ja nicht ansprechen.
Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite
macht natürlich
ich bin durchaus
Freund von signierten Apps
zum Beispiel.
Dass sie aber halt alle nur von Apple signiert
sein dürfen, ist dann auch wieder ein Problem.
Wir gehen auch mal sogar noch einen Schritt weiter mit den Notarized-Apps,
die jetzt angekündigt wurden, dass du sogar die Apps, die nicht von
Apple distributed werden, zu Apple vorher schickst,
die dir deine Apps signieren, die schicken sie dir zurück
und dann kannst du sie auf deiner Webseite Leuten zum Download angeben.
Und irgendwann wird macOS wahrscheinlich nur noch
notarisierte Apps
bei default starten.
Ist ja an und für sich nicht verkehrt.
An und für sich nicht.
Es sei denn, du bist selber Softwareentwickler
und musstest in deinen Bildprozess
einen sehr asynchron
eine Woche wartenden Schritt.
Es gibt Cases,
wo du dein eigenes Snake Oil Zertifikat installieren musst,
wo du dann beim Bauen deine Software selber zertifizierst
mit diesem Snake Oil Zertifikat,
was du bei dir in der CI eingebaut hast,
nur damit es in der CI auch ausgeführt werden kann.
Ich habe übrigens noch das offene Ticket bei Rust,
dass ich endlich mal möchte,
dass wir unsere Mac und Windows Installer auch ordentlich signieren.
Die werden nur so selten verwendet.
Also ein Riesenprozess.
Das Problem an der Stelle ist weniger,
es nicht möglich wäre, über
Mozilla irgendwie ein Zertifikat zu bekommen.
Also wir würden uns ein eigenes
Zertifikat holen, sondern dass wir irgendwie überlegen müssen,
wo ist der Fast-Story,
in der das reinhört, wer darf an diesem
Ding rumfingern, weil ansonsten können wir uns den Tanz auch einfach
sparen. Das stimmt.
Wenn du nicht gut genug drauf aufpassen kannst, dann
ist es halt nichts wert.
Genau. Das ist durchaus
ein interessantes Problem für so Open-Source-Projekte,
weil die meisten Open-Source-Projekte halt komplett
im Offenen sind, aber dann hast
du dann doch Stellen, wo du halt sagst,
wenn wir das eigentlich machen wollen.
Ich meine, natürlich alle
Schlüssel, die man braucht, um unsere
Bildinfrastruktur
zum Beispiel zu benutzen, um
ein Rust-Release zu bauen und so weiter und so fort,
da haben wir das Problem ja eh schon.
Man muss auch
trotzdem drüber nachdenken, wer hat Zugriff und wie
funktionieren die Prozesse, ganz klar. Genau, wer
signiert die Releases und
das ist natürlich auch immer so ein Problem. Wie ist der Prozess?
Kannst du da ein bisschen was erzählen?
Ich kenne den nicht. Der ändert sich auch regelmäßig,
der muss eine Weile lang ziemlich haarig gewesen sein.
Also vor kurzem hat man das mal so,
vor kurzem kam ja so die Diskussion auf,
dass wir mehr Point-Releases haben.
Also wir hatten dann 0.14, 0.14.1
und dann plötzlich wurden die Point-Releases immer mehr,
wo wir kleine Bugs gefixt haben.
Dann haben die Leute gesagt,
wird die Software hier instabiler und so weiter und so fort.
Es fallen bloß die Probleme eher auf.
Ja, nee, nicht nur das.
Also es gab halt Sachen,
die wurden einfach bis zum nächsten Release nicht gefixt,
weil die nicht so kritisch waren.
Einfach auch.
und da hat
Steve dann auch richtig zugeschrieben,
naja, der interne Prozess ist da auch einfach besser geworden,
das heißt, es ist jetzt leichter für uns einfach
zu sagen, drei Patches auf dem Branch
und bitte release das als
N26.1, war das
ein großen Teil ein manueller Prozess.
Und
wie das bei vielen Sachen so ist, man will nicht
wissen, wie die was gemacht wird. Also es ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie unsicher oder sonst wie, sondern das war halt
lange Zeit, da hatte halt
eine Textdatei, die muss dann halt von oben nach unten
durchgegangen werden und
es war nicht immer so, dass man einfach hier auf
Release
hauen konnte.
So einen schönen großen roten Buzzerbutton,
draufhaut, bam, neues Release ist raus.
Das finde ich cool. Ich will irgendwann irgendwas arbeiten,
wo man sowas macht.
Ich bin an den Engineering-Prozessen,
ich beobachte die,
aber ich bin da halt nicht so viel dran,
weil ich nicht auf den Compiler kontribute.
Jetzt haben wir dich gar nicht richtig vorgestellt.
Stimmt, wie lange reden wir da eigentlich schon?
Schon seit Annerstag.
Oh Gott, was schön.
Wer bist du eigentlich?
Genau, wir beide kennen uns dadurch, dass ich kleine Fühler in der Rust-Community habe
und du sehr aktiv in der Rust-Community mitmachst.
Ja.
Was machst du denn da so?
Ein Kesselbuntes.
Ich habe vor Jahren, Jahren angefangen, was zu lernen.
Das war jetzt schon so fast fünf Jahre.
Und irgendwann wurde es mir ein bisschen leid.
Und ich habe die Usergruppe in Berlin zusammen gegründet
mit einem anderen, dem es leid war, dem Jan Hochmann.
So als Selbsthilfegruppe gerade.
Ja, wirklich.
Also wir haben einfach gesagt, ich möchte nicht alleine lernen.
Das ist so hart zusammen.
Das machen wir jetzt schon eine ganze Weile lang.
Es ist die aktivste Usergruppe weltweit.
Es ist nicht die größte.
Nicht schlecht.
San Francisco kann man immer nicht schlagen.
Aktiv heißt, ihr habt die meisten Veranstaltungen.
Wir haben die meisten Veranstaltungen.
Wir haben momentan auch drei Sub-Veranstaltungen seit diesem Monat.
Also wir haben ein regelmäßiges Hack-and-Learn.
Wir haben ein ganz klassisches Talk-Meetup.
Und wir haben so ein Show-and-Tell.
Und wir sind jetzt inzwischen in der Größe,
wo wir auch einfach sagen,
es gibt inzwischen mehrere Meetups.
Man kann da überhaupt nicht mehr auf einem sein.
Das ist auch alles nicht, also das Show & Tell habe ich nicht gemacht,
die Talk Meetups mache ich auch nicht und so, also ich hatte
meine Finger nicht mehr drin.
Und so seit fast 1.0
wurde ich angesprochen,
ich habe früher viel in der Ruby Community
organisiert, habe damals Konferenzen organisiert,
bin auch immer noch Vorstand vom Ruby Berlin
e.V.
Und da
bekam ich
irgendwann ein Mail von Steve Kratnick, der fragte,
sag mal, wir gründen hier ein Community-Team,
wir müssen nicht mitmachen.
hat sich so ein bisschen all die Leute, die er so kannte,
zusammengesucht. Wenn man das alte Community-Team
anschaut, der ist einmal durch die Ruby-Community
hat gesagt, die machen alle gute Arbeit.
Das ist bloß zwei Buchstaben anders als Ruby, ne?
Das war ja erstaunlich, der Overland zwischen den
Ruby und was verschillt.
Und hat sich die Leute ein bisschen zusammengesucht
und hat gesagt, das Tolle ist,
hier kriegt ihr Blankslate.
Und vor allem, und das muss ich
sagen, da hat er auch nicht Unrecht, ihr kriegt
freie Hand.
Er ist einfach noch nicht so eingesessen
und entsprechend
sind die Diskussionen an vielen Stellen
eigentlich mehr so, dass man
das Community-Team häufiger mal gesagt kriegen muss,
hey Leute, könnt ihr einfach selbstentscheidend machen
als irgendwie andersrum. Das ist sehr angenehm.
Im Community-Team, das hat sich
inzwischen aufgespüttet und ist größer.
Wir haben ein Internationalisierungsteam,
wir haben ein
Team, das sich um Content,
also wenn ihr einen Blogpost schreibt,
kann man
den redirigieren
lassen und gegenlesen lassen.
wir haben das ganz klassische Community Team
sich um alles kümmert, wir haben ein Team, das
Surveys macht und jedes Jahr schaut
wie steht es eigentlich in der Rust Community, der hat jetzt gerade
angefangen und ich leite
inzwischen das Event Team, ich habe nämlich
zwischendurch noch das Rust Fest gegründet
was die größte Konferenz in Europa
ist, die einzige aber
die größte Rust Konferenz
das aus deiner Hand wird jetzt schon, wäre super cool
ich wusste gar nicht, dass das, also ich kannte die Origin
Story vom Rust Fest nicht, aber das
finde ich cool
Ja, und das Wasfest
habe ich, genau,
ich wollte einfach eine Konferenz haben
und ich hatte eine ganze Menge Erfahrung damit, auch mit
verschiedenen Sachen und
wollte auch, dass die erste Konferenz, die es in Europa
gibt, einfach auch gut ist,
in gewissen Standards
und
so aufgezogen ist, wie ich denke,
dass Open Source Konferenzen aufgezogen werden sollen
und es fängt wieder,
da kommt
ja, da kommt wieder das leidige Thema,
das fängt beim Geld an.
Also Rustfest ist schon immer
voll durchkalkuliert.
Und also
man kann ja
so kalkulieren,
dass man billig unterwegs ist,
aber trotzdem irgendwie ein Budget hat, von dem man irgendwie
leben kann.
Das ist nicht kommerziell, also wir kriegen da alle kein Geld
für, aber
wie das unser einer Co-Organizer, Jan-Erik
so schön sagt, meine bevorzugte
Problemlösungsstrategie ist,
ich gebe dir mein Geld, das sich damit auskennt.
Das passiert meistens.
Gerade als Softwareentwickler
neigt man ja auch häufig dazu,
zu versuchen, es selbst zu machen und dann
unendlich viel Zeit zu verschwenden damit.
Ich habe einmal versucht, Videoproduktionen für eine Konferenz
zu machen. Ich habe das am Ende einem Kumpel gegeben.
Der hat gesagt, ich müsste ja leider
Betrag X für abknöpfen. Das ist im Übrigen
nicht weniger, als ich verlangt hätte, wenn ich gleich
auf die Konferenz gekommen wäre, Video mitgeliehen hätte
und das einfach direkt sonntags
auf YouTube veröffentlicht hätte.
Aber das ist zur Erfahrung, die man macht.
Du hast vorher schon Rubikonferenzen organisiert?
Ich habe vorher das HeroCamp organisiert,
was eine sehr schöne Konferenz war.
Leider haben sich da sehr, sehr viele Leute
sehr, sehr angestrengt für,
was dazu führt, dass es sie nicht mehr gibt.
Und alle hoffen,
dass es sie mal wieder gibt,
aber die Leute wissen,
was sie machen muss.
Und wie verhinderst du das bei der Rustfest?
sich Leute so auflösen
oder verbrennen bei der
Arbeit? Wir verteilen es ein bisschen
mehr. Wasfest hat sich ein bisschen
von der Europol inspirieren lassen.
Das ist ja die
klassische Ruby-Konferenz und die reist jedes Jahr
woanders hin. Wasfest findet
alle halbe Jahr statt, aber
es ist immer ein anderes Team an einem
anderen Ort, hat Vorteile, hat Nachteile.
Der Nachteil ist natürlich,
du hast immer wieder Leute, die sowas noch nie
gemacht haben. Der Vorteil
ist glaube ich für so eine Community, dass sich das
diese Erfahrung so ein bisschen verteilt.
Also es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn irgendwann mal
eine von diesen Communities hingeht und sagt,
wir machen das schon letztes Jahr in Paris, wir machen
dieses Jahr einfach unser eigenes Ding. Finde ich auch total gut.
Es sind immer mehr Leute, die auch das schon mal gemacht haben.
Genau, ich bin auch durchaus der Meinung,
dass aus verschiedenen Gründen, ich wäre,
es gibt viele Leute, die sagen, es gibt zu viele Konferenzen,
ich bin der Meinung, es gibt nicht genügend Konferenzen.
Gar in Europa.
Genau, weil auch einfach
Themen,
es gibt ein riesiges Set an Themen,
die man einfach mal durchackern könnte,
die vielleicht eher
Spartenthemen sind und kleinere
Konferenzen organisieren sich besser.
Ein Raum für 50, da kann ich irgendwo,
da kann ich eine Firma fragen, sagt man, habt ihr irgendwo einen Raum?
Für 200 habe ich schon ein Problem,
für 400 wird es langsam schwierig,
dann gibt es in Berlin nur noch ganz wenig Orte,
wo ich das veranstalten kann.
Für 15.000 muss man nach Leipzig.
Naja,
wenn du mal guckst, also Sachen, die in
Europa herausstechen, sind halt gleich
dann auch so richtig große Dinger.
Sowas wie Meetings C++ oder sowas.
Das ist halt eine Riesengeschichte.
Das wird auch von wenigen Leuten gestemmt und ziemlich gut gemacht,
aber dann hörst du wiederum,
wenn du dich mal mit zum Beispiel Steve Klepnik unterhältst
oder den Leuten, die so
gerade als Redner in der Tech-Szene
sehr bekannt sind, die
kommen halt mal eben vorbei und halten
einen Vortrag über was, weil den haben sie in den USA
da schon fünfmal gehalten,
weil sie einmal am Monat auf einer anderen
Ruby-Konferenz sind und
das so regelmäßig halten. Das wäre eigentlich was, was man
in Europa fast auch holen könnte.
Was ja immer irritierenderweise so
bisschen verpönt ist, Vorträge mehrfach
halten, finde ich gar nicht
problematisch, weil
viele Leute einfach, also
das Publikum überschneidet sich
ja selten. Also die Leute,
die auf fünf Konferenzen im Jahr gehen
und sich dann beschweren, dass sie diesen Vortrag schon mal gehört haben
und jetzt gerade irgendwie rausgehen müssen und eine rauchen,
die sind wirklich
minimal greifen. Also ich finde
das bei Konferenzen immer relativ interessant,
wie viele Leute da sehr stark Meinungen
zu haben, die
sehr mittelmäßig sind. Also als ich angefangen
Das ist ein sehr opinionated Publikum.
Als ich angefangen habe, Konferenzen zu veranstalten
im Eurocamp,
da war zum Beispiel,
das erste Eurocamp war 2012.
Da hieß es noch,
cool, ihr habt einen Code of Conduct.
Heutzutage Standard bei jeder Konferenz.
Ihr habt keinen Code of Conduct.
Genau.
Aber das erste Eurocamp,
da rede ich auch ganz offen drüber, ist pleite gegangen.
Da mussten wir uns von den Leuten
ein bisschen Geld leihen, damit wir überhaupt am Ende
Interessant.
Nicht gleich, hätte das Ende von
Ruby Berlin sein können.
Und wir sind nicht, also
wir sind 4000 Euro unter
Budget
reingekommen.
Das ließ sich schon noch fixen und so.
Aber das hatte so ein paar Eigenarten, die man jetzt zum Beispiel
beim Rustfest noch merkt. Beim Rustfest kriegst du
zum Beispiel keinen kostenlosen Alkohol.
Warum haben wir das
damals nicht gemacht? Wir haben damals gedacht, eigentlich für eine Konferenz
da brauchst du irgendwie eine Party mit kostenlosem Alkohol.
aber wir hatten halt kein Geld dafür.
Und dann haben wir festgestellt,
es hat sich niemand darüber beschwert und dann haben wir es uns
durchgedacht und wenn ihr auf einer Konferenz
seid und da gibt es kostenlos Alkohol,
dann habt ihr das über euer Ticket schon querfinanziert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich kostenlos
Alkohol generell unterstützenswert finde, aber okay,
klar, die Gedanken muss man natürlich erstmal haben.
Es kommt auch immer ein bisschen darauf an,
in welcher Community das stattfindet,
also bei so einer Veranstaltung.
BeerCon.
Wenn ich zu einer Apple-Entwickler-Konferenz
selbst zu einer Ruby-Konferenz,
wo auch ganz wesentlich mehr Entwickler
dahinterstehen oder einer C++-Geschichte,
der erwarte ich nicht,
aber dann gehe ich davon aus, dass da eine ganze Menge
mehr Geld in der Organisation mit drinsteckt.
Wenn ich zu sowas kleinem gehe wie dem Rustfest,
was ja noch am Entstehen ist
oder beziehungsweise wo die Community
noch im Entstehen ist und wo man weiß, dass da nicht viel
dahintersteht bislang.
Der Rustfest hat ein Budget von 70.000 Euro.
Euro Event.
Okay.
Wir geben das Geld nur einfach anders aus.
Naja, man kann damit einfach aggressiv umgehen.
Die Leute geben Geld für Rustfest aus,
weil wir zum Beispiel zu Sponsoren gehen und sagen,
hey Leute, wenn ihr Rust-Entwickler sucht,
und Entwicklerinnen dann kommt einfach aufs Rustfest,
da findet ihr die, es bedeutend billiger als ein Recruiter.
Das stimmt.
Und wenn man sich anschaut, was Recruiter kosten,
da sind 10.000 Euro Platinum-Sponsoring einfach richtig billig.
Das sind auch eben Flugtickets für zwei Leute,
die sich die Vorträge eh ansehen wollen.
Also mit diesen Rechnungen muss man einfach mal umgehen und daher kommt auch meine Haltung, dass sich die Open Source Community mehr um Geld kümmern sollte, weil das Geld ist da.
Wenn ihr euch mal einfach anschaut, was in Konferenzen veranstaltet wird und die kosten, einfach nur mal so als Hausnummer, ein Tag mit Mittagessen bei einer Venue kostet pro Person 70 Euro.
Die muss natürlich irgendwie reinkommen.
Und da musst du dir dann halt überlegen,
ob das Bier für 3,50 noch sein muss.
Und deswegen gibt es beim Rustfest zum Beispiel auch keine T-Shirts.
Weil ein T-Shirt würde 5 Euro pro Person kosten.
Das würde halt auf den Ticketpreis gehen.
Schade fand ich es ja schon.
Wir überlegen uns, ob wir das mit den T-Shirts nicht langsam mal einführen.
Aber es gibt auch viele Leute, die schmeißen die Dinge halt am Ende.
Es gibt da auch andere Lösungen für zum Beispiel.
Du kannst einfach anklickern, ich hätte gerne ein T-Shirt
und dann koste ich irgendwie nochmal 5 Euro mehr oder so.
Hast du da ein bisschen Einblick, wie die Rust-Conf organisiert wird?
weil da gab es ja bei den letzten Veranstaltungen
immer, wir haben dieses T-Shirt bekommen
und wir haben diese Socken bekommen.
Ich habe da ein bisschen
ein Gefühl, die RAS-Conf wird
vom RAS-Projekt produziert
und entsprechend sind die
Leute, die
die RAS-Conf veranstalten, dafür auch
bezahlt, was natürlich
auch völlig angemessen ist.
Und
entsprechend haben die da einfach auch ganz
andere Budgets.
Weil das die offizielle Veranstaltung
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen die Frage, wie es mit offiziell und nicht offiziell ist.
Also es ist zum Beispiel momentan auch eine Frage, was hat eigentlich das Events-Team zur Waskampf zu sagen und was nicht.
Ich habe an der Waskampf leider so die eine oder andere Kritik, die auch ein bisschen daherkommt.
Das habe ich in der Ruby-Community auch schon mal ein bisschen bemerkt, dass die großen Konferenzen, also so die Zentralkonferenzen immer hinten dran sind.
Die Ruby-Conf war immer hinten dran, hinter allen Entwicklungen.
Also das habe ich ganz stark bemerkt.
Was meinen Sie mit hinten ran?
Die haben sich immer noch zwei Jahre, also wenn irgendwie die Standards gestiegen sind,
haben sich diese Konferenzen immer noch so zwei Jahre Zeit gelassen.
Achso, die letzten, die einen Code of Conduct haben?
Nicht nur das, also Code of Conduct sind ja inzwischen auch wieder so ein bisschen kritisiert,
als viele Konferenzen haben sie einfach und haben sich nicht damit beschäftigt, wie man die durchsetzt.
Was machst du eigentlich, wenn es zu einem Vorfall kommt?
und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist ja eigentlich das Wichtige.
Also so ein bisschen Text auf die Webseite
zu schreiben, das ist das eine, aber halt auch wirklich
dafür zu sorgen, dass deine Konferenz das auch
einhält und vielleicht auch, da
verpennen es ja viele Konferenzen,
wenn du selbst gegen deinen Code of Conduct verstößt,
dann ist jede Kritik berechtigt,
muss ich ehrlich sagen. Und dann bitte nicht
rumreden von wegen, ja, aber wir sind
doch hier Community-Konferenz oder sonst was. Wenn ich das
halt irgendwie auf meine Webseite packe, dann habe ich
mich da gefälligst auch dran zu halten.
Also sich aufs hohe Ross zu stellen,
also nicht aufs hohe Ross, sondern sich irgendwie
zu sagen, wir wollen da einen Standard
erhöhen, aber wir selbst sind ausgenommen, geht halt
einfach überhaupt nicht. Deswegen, da gibt es
viele Details drum, aber zum Beispiel
was das Eurocamp dann 2014
gemacht hat, wir hatten 2013, hatten wir
einen Keynote-Speaker, der saß im
Rollstuhl und da sind wir mal
beim, das war aber zum Hotel
und wie läuft denn das alles? Wir sind
ja alle Amateure und unerfahren, aber
da sind wir
ohne Frage natürlich
haben wir aufs Hotel zugegangen,
dabei erstmal festgestellt,
man kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass
ein Hotel
in Deutschland einem
direkt sagen kann, wie sie mit so einer Situation
umgehen.
Das beliebteste, was man hört, ist, wir haben da drei Stufen,
können Sie die Person da einfach hochheben. Nein, das geht nicht.
Das ist
einfach sackeunfreundlich.
Das ist eine Notlösung, aber man
veranstaltet eine Konferenz, da gibt es gefährlichst keine
Notlösungen eingeplant.
mit dem E-Rollstuhl schon gar nicht mehr zu machen.
Auch einfach mal so.
Und
dann haben wir 2014 gedacht, hey, das sieht doch alles
letztes Jahr total gut.
Aber warum steht das eigentlich nicht
auf unserer Webseite? Und dann sind wir einfach mal hingegangen,
sind einfach mal alles
durchgegangen, was wir eigentlich haben.
Irgendwie Live-Transkriptionen und so weiter
und so fort, haben das alles auf die Webseite gepackt.
Und siehe da, plötzlich
kommen Menschen mit Behinderung.
Weil
alles auf dieser Webseite, was für Speaker und
sonst wo der Ort ist und
wie du hinfährst, wie du mit der S-Bahn hinkommst und sonst
was, aber nicht, ob das Rollstuhl...
Und viele sind es wahrscheinlich gewohnt,
dass sie sich dann sagen, ach, das wird wahrscheinlich für mich eh nicht
gut ausgerichtet sein,
deswegen gehe ich gar nicht erst hin.
Und dann meldest du dich
bei Konferenzen, bei denen du
zum Beispiel weißt, dass eigentlich die, wenn du
ordentlich hast, wie zum Beispiel bei der
RubyConf, und die RubyConf hat sich erstmal zwei Jahre
Zeit gelassen, so, von wegen so.
Das haben wir noch nie so gemacht.
Hammer aufgenommen,
Hammer aufgenommen, finden wir gerade nicht so wichtig.
Und das finde ich eine ganz
bemerkenswerte Aussage von Konferenzen,
die sich um Diversity kümmern. Wenn es um Behinderung
geht, dass sie dann sagen, haben wir aufgenommen,
das finden wir erstmal nicht so wichtig, das ist uns zu viel Aufwand.
Es ist auch gar nicht so viel Aufwand. Also beim
Viewcamp 2014 war der
Aufwand allen Ernstes,
einmal gucken, dass das
Hotel zugänglich
ist, gucken, dass das
Speaker Dinner zugänglich ist und einmal alle
Wege laufen. Ich bin da einmal
am Samstag raus und bin einmal irgendwie
alle Wege von der Partylocation zum
Warner Uni. Seitdem
veranstalte ich zum Beispiel auch super gerne an Unis,
weil an Unis sind viele von
diesen Problemen einfach gelöst, weil das
öffentliche Gebäude sind
in Hotels, gerade in Deutschland.
Nicht unbedingt.
Hotels auch noch ein bisschen besser,
aber es gibt eine ganze Menge
Venues, die auch sehr gerne genommen werden,
wo ich echt sagen muss,
geht halt nicht.
Und aus verschiedenen Gründen, ich habe mein Ziviles bei der Lebenshilfe gemacht, das ist ein Thema, das mir sehr am Herzen liegt, und habe da mal verschiedene Konferenzen immer angeschrieben, habe auch mal eine Webseite mit den Sozialhelden zusammengebaut, rampup.me, die überall rumgereicht wird, außer in der IT-Community.
Also ich sehe die heute auf Twitter, aber nie von IT-Accounts.
Das ist auch eine ganz interessante.
Ich habe gerade überlegt, man könnte eigentlich das auch automatisch lösen,
indem man vielleicht in sowas wie die RealMap reinguckt,
ob das Venue dort irgendwie einen grünen Punkt hat oder einen grünen Haken hat.
Ja, könnte man machen.
Zum Beispiel, ja, das verwenden wir häufig zur Recherche.
Aber es ist eigentlich gar nicht so viel Aufwand,
zumindest mal so Basis, alles abzugehen.
Und das Weitere ist einfach noch, wir haben immer eine E-Mail.
Das Wichtigste ist eigentlich, dass wir unten in diesem Accessibility-Statement immer stehen haben.
Im Übrigen, wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen habt,
nehmen wir für euch ein Ticket aus dem Verkauf.
Schreibt uns eine E-Mail, wir nehmen euch sofort ein Ticket aus dem Verkauf.
Und wir melden uns bei euch,
wenn wir wissen, dass wir dieses Problem lösen können.
Das ist wertvoll.
Weil viele Konferenzen inzwischen auch schnell ausverkauft sind.
Wastfest hat das Problem glücklicherweise nicht,
aber Subkonferenzen, die sind ja
JS-Konf.eu oder sonst was,
sind ja ratzfatz für die.
Wenn du irgendwelche Sonderfragen hast,
dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass du wahrscheinlich kein Geld mehr bekommst.
Da muss ich mich wohl jetzt schon um die Tickets für nächstes Jahr machen.
Genau.
Und da finde ich es dann immer interessant,
Konferenzen.
Letzte Woche hatte ich ein Positivbeispiel.
Die Leute von Tito
haben mich angeschrieben, dass sie jetzt eine Konferenz machen.
Tito verkauft Tickets für Konferenzen.
Schöne Konferenz und danke,
dass ihr mir ein Rabatt für ein Ticket geben wollt, aber
Flug nach Chicago.
Könnt ihr mir den auch noch bezahlen?
Nee, also mich könnt ihr mir
auch noch bezahlen, aber
ob das jetzt 100 Euro teurer oder
weniger wird, das macht den Bock jetzt auch nicht.
Und
Aber ihr habt eine schöne Venue und ihr habt eigentlich eine gute Webseite, auf der das alles dokumentiert ist.
Wollt ihr das nicht alles auf eurer Webseite ziehen?
Und 24 Stunden später hatte ich eine Mail.
Hi, wir haben hier, vielen Dank für die Info.
Und wir haben da mal aus eurem und aus noch ein paar anderen Ressourcen, die wir hier gelesen haben, was zusammengeschrieben.
Ich glaube, bei denen klaue ich es nächstes Mal.
Ich gebe da ungemein ungern Beratung bei, außer dass ich darauf hinweise, dass das Problem ist.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, auf die man achten muss, aber die viele machen sie nicht.
Ja, also einmal gibt es natürlich das Problem, dass die Standards weltweit sehr unterschiedlich sind, das andere an der Seite ist auch noch, ich bin da auch nur Amateur und ich finde es eigentlich bedeutend besser, wenn Konferenzen das als Problem sehen und sich dann Leute suchen, die unter Umständen betroffen sind oder damit Erfahrung haben.
Also ich würde sehr empfehlen, nicht das zu kopieren, was das was festmacht, weil was das was festmacht ist halt auch nur eine Amateurleistung.
Es gibt da noch bedeutend mehr Dinge, die man tun kann.
Man kann sich davon natürlich inspirieren lassen,
aber wenn man das halt machen möchte, sollte man sich Leute suchen,
am besten Betroffene suchen, die das machen
und unter Umständen sich vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen Geld in die Hand nehmen.
Mich würde es auch gar nicht wundern,
wenn es Leute gibt, die das als Service anbieten.
Natürlich.
Nein, aber was mir gerade eingefallen ist,
na gut, okay, das mit dem Code of Conduct ist seit einigen Jahren jetzt so,
dass es sich unter den Konferenzen ausbreitet,
aber das war vor einigen Jahren noch nicht so.
Jetzt das Problem mit der Accessibility und das Bekanntmachen,
dass man überhaupt diese Awareness schafft
und dass man es auch wirklich verbreitet,
dass man eventuell accessible ist, das ist das Nächste.
Also es will mir jetzt eigentlich eine Checkliste,
für worauf man achten muss.
Und eine andere Sache wäre, gibt es vielleicht Leute,
die sich, zum Beispiel wie die Leute hinter der Wheelmap,
die sagen, wir helfen euch gerne dabei, darauf zu achten, sowas zu machen und das quasi als Dienstleistung machen.
Das machen die witzigerweise.
Also die Sozialhelden hinter der BMAP, die kann man anschreiben und sagen, wir hätten da gerne Beratung,
aber die möchten halt einfach Geld für.
Sinnvollerweise.
Genau, die machen davon ihren Lebensunterhalt.
Wenn man ein Community-Projekt ist, dann fangen die auch nicht viel Geld für.
Also die lassen das ja mit sich reden, aber die Sozialhelden sind halt auch ein Verein,
von denen sich verschiedene Leute ihren Lebensunterhalt bestreiten für die Arbeit, die sie tun.
Und entsprechend finde ich es auch durchaus gut, dass man für diese Leistung bezahlt.
Ich muss dazu auf der anderen Seite halt wieder sagen, in Konferenzen ist wirklich viel Geld unterwegs.
Ich finde es immer sehr schwierig, wenn Konferenzen nur darauf verweisen, wir sind ein Community-Projekt.
Und wir möchten es deswegen nicht machen und deswegen haben wir kein Geld, zum Beispiel Leuten Fahrtkosten zu bezahlen.
Rastfest bezahlt zum Beispiel zum Diversity-Ticket
Fahrt und Flug und Hotel mit.
Warum?
Weil das natürlich heißt, wir können nicht nur Leute
von vor Ort einladen, sondern wir können halt durchaus
auch mal Leute aus
Südamerika oder sonst was oder
von irgendwie
Hinterland in Indien einladen, die halt erstmal
mit dem Zug zum Flughafen fahren müssen und dann herfliegen,
die sich das gar nicht bestreiten können.
So ist das auch, wenn man in Dresden wohnt.
Und so verbreitet
man eine Community natürlich sehr stark,
die man Leute halt reinholt.
Und solche Sachen lassen sich alles machen,
wenn man das am Anfang mit einem Spitzenbeaststück durchrechnet.
Und deswegen muss das einfach am Anfang Budget sein.
Da steht einfach, also bei uns steht beim Rustfest einfach drin,
Betrag X für solche Sachen,
Betrag X für Accessibility.
Und da muss ich auch ehrlich sagen,
wo wir wieder bei Community-Finanzierung sind,
dieser Betrag X, der matcht so in etwa ganz gut damit,
was wir an Supporter-Tickets kriegen.
Also man kann bei Rustfest kaufen das normale Ticket
oder halt für 200 Euro das doppelt so teure Supporter-Ticket.
Das finde ich zum Beispiel eine sehr gute Sache beim CCC.
Also dass das bei allen CCC-Events einfach gemacht wird,
dass man sagt, das ist das kostendeckende Ticket,
das ist das Ticket für Leute, die es sich leisten können
und das ist das Ticket für Leute, die es sich eben leisten können,
wo man das auch so ein bisschen solidarisch aufzieht.
Und da muss ich ehrlich sagen,
dieses Geld möchte ich halt nicht unbedingt in eine Party fließen lassen,
sondern es stirbt richtig halt eben
in Community-Arbeit fließen lassen.
Da kann man auch sagen, wenn wir eine Party zum Schluss
schmeißen, dann kann das auch gerne
vielleicht eine gesponserte Party sein.
Es hat viel mit Wollen zu tun.
Wir haben begonnen,
allen Leuten ihre Aufwände
für Talks und so weiter zu zahlen,
also zumindest Kostenlogie
und Flug und so weiter und so fort.
Und als wir das begonnen haben,
haben wir gedacht, kriegen wir das hin?
Aber wir wollen es.
dann hast du das einfach von Tag 1 im Budget drin.
Wenn du es nicht im Budget drin hast, wirst du es nicht kriegen.
Es gibt Konferenzen, die nicht so viel Geld haben.
Die können andere Lösungen finden.
Zum Beispiel viele Konferenzen sagen halt,
wir bezahlen Leuten aus Europa 200 Euro für die Anreise
und Leuten aus Interkontinental 400 Euro.
Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen,
ich finde es immer ein bisschen verwirrend,
wenn man eine Konferenz hat, die jetzt in Spanien stattfindet.
und sind keine Leute aus Spanien auf der Bühne.
Warum?
Also ihr habt sicherlich Leute, die da...
Weil die für die Anreise kein Geld bekommen haben.
Ja, nee, weil man auch irgendwie
ein bisschen präsentieren möchte,
was haben wir hier alles anfliegen können.
Aber das ist durchaus,
also so kalkulieren wir auch,
wir sagen zum Beispiel auch durchaus
bei der Auswahl am Ende
gucken wir durchaus, was uns die Speaker kosten
und laden halt nicht irgendwie
zwölf Leute aus den USA ein,
sondern ein paar Leute vor Ort,
paar Leute aus Europa, paar Leute von Übersee.
Das finde ich auch völlig okay.
Das ist absolut richtig.
Man will ja auch ein bisschen,
nicht mal dieselben, aber auch nicht mal aus derselben
Geografenregion diese Leute mit den selben Interessen einladen,
sondern komplett wirklich diversifizieren.
Vielleicht sind ja ganz andere Sachen, die dann angesprochen werden,
ganz andere Thematiken.
In weit loco.
Und so gibt es da eine ganze Menge Praxis.
Locally grown, locally sourced.
Ja, so gibt es da eine ganze Menge Praxis drum.
Das finde ich ganz interessant.
Wir haben momentan,
vielleicht muss ich es ein bisschen zu Ende zu bringen,
aber auch noch was zu pitchen,
versuchen wir gerade als Events-Team bei Rust was zu schreiben.
Das ist ein kleiner Events-Planner für Open-Source-Konferenzen,
wo wir mal versuchen,
das kommt aus einem Workshop,
den ich beim Rust-Fest das letzte Mal gemacht habe,
wo wir einfach mal jeden Einzeltask,
den man für so eine kleine Konferenz braucht,
aufgeschrieben haben.
Also ich möchte X haben und folgende Tasks fallen raus.
Ich habe da auch ein paar Bilder von.
kann ich später mal noch zeigen.
Und es ist überraschend,
dass zum Beispiel Kümmern um Essen,
da fallen irgendwie
15 Tickets bei raus
und Basic Accessibility
sind halt zwei.
Das sind halt so die Relationen.
Und dann beschweren sich aber die Leute darüber,
dass Accessibility so viel Arbeit ist.
Wir haben keine Zeit für sowas.
Das ist halt auch was, was bei den meisten Leuten,
die nicht betroffen sind, einfach nicht auf dem Schirm ist.
Ja, das ist auch ein generelles Problem von Accessibility.
Dass es viele Leute auf dem Schirm ist,
weil die meisten halt einfach denken, dass es sie nicht betrifft,
aber das tut es trotzdem.
Ja, aber cooles Tool, gibt es da einen coolen Namen für?
Das war unter anderem der FOSS Events Planner.
Langweilig, aber cool.
Wir hoffen, dass wir ihn bis Ende des Jahres fertig haben,
ein paar andere Sachen gerade zu machen, aber ja.
Ja, cool, vielen Dank, dass du uns ein bisschen Einblick
in die Rustfest-Orga gegeben hast an der Stelle.
Du, Hendrik, wir haben übrigens noch Feedback zur letzten Folge
bekommen für unseren Errata-Blog,
den wir jetzt neu einfüllen.
Oh, shit.
Nee, wir haben ja schon erstmal Feedback bekommen.
Dietmar hat sich der Schmittlauch gemeldet.
Und wir haben letztes Mal über DNS...
Schmittlauch ist übrigens der
wahrscheinlich am häufigsten erwähnte
Hörer in unserer Sendung. Schmittlauch und Jörg.
Genau.
Nee, wir haben doch über DNS gesprochen.
Und vor allem DNS über TLS.
Haben wir total unterschlagen.
Genau. Stimmt, ja.
nicht angesprochen werden. DNS über
HTTPS, über HTTPS angesprochen,
aber nicht... Ach Gott,
das bringt sich neinander.
Also ich glaube, er hatte die Beschwerde, dass wir über
DNS geredet haben und so getan hätten,
als wäre die einzige
sichere Alternative zu Plain Old
DNS, DNS over
HTTPS und es gibt auch
parallel dazu DNS over TLS.
Das hatten wir beide jetzt einfach nicht so auf dem Schirm.
Ja gut, das gibt es also auch
der Vollständigkeit halber, sei das hier mal erwähnt.
Vielen lieben Dank für das Feedback.
Wir nehmen jederzeit gerne
Korrekturen entgegen.
Links mit weiteren Infos gibt es natürlich in den Show Notes.
Cool.
Ja,
an der ersten Stelle würde ich sagen, es reicht langsam.
Cooler Abschluss.
Vielen Dank, Florian,
dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, mit uns zu reden.
Das war sehr aufschlussreich.
Wo finden dich denn
Leute online?
Nur groß ist es auf Twitter und auf GitHub.
Links wahrscheinlich in den Shownotes.
Gut, also dein Twitter-Handle
und dein GitHub packen wir
in die Shownotes.
Du machst ja auch Rust-Training.
Das heißt, man findet auch immer
auf deinem GitHub noch ein paar Beispiele
für Projekte. Genau, also
mein GitHub ist ein Sammelsorium
aus kleinen Dingen, die ich mal
in Trainings gebaut habe. Man sieht auch mal
ein komplettes Training online.
Das findet sich
verlinken wir auch mal in den Show Notes.
Da muss ich allerdings
dazu sagen, dass
editiere ich großteils halt
selbst und insofern
kann ich nicht immer dafür garantieren, dass alles gerade
super aktuell ist.
Du hältst gerade mal einen Vortrag vor Code Reviewern beim
Nationalen. Genau. Ne, das war
ja ein Training.
Entsprechend
sind die Folien halt meine Arbeitsfolien,
aber wer die haben möchte,
die sind auf Deutsch, Englisch und jemand
übersetzt sie auf Spanisch. Ich nehme auch gerne
weitere Übersetzungen und Hilfen und Publikation
und so weiter und man darf sie natürlich auch frei verwenden.
Ich
finde es ein bisschen schade, dass es nicht
genügend Schulungsmaterial gibt, das
frei und open source ist.
Weil Schulungen
sich meiner Meinung nach nicht dadurch auszeichnen,
dass man so, dass alle Leute
irgendwie super Material bauen.
Meistens zeichnen sich
dadurch aus, dass Leute das
beibebringen, die gut sind.
Und deswegen möchte ich das so ein bisschen
verbreiten.
Ansonsten habe ich eine kleine Firma,
skera.de
und eine kleine Rust-Firma, die jetzt
auch mal in Gründung ist,
die wir wahrscheinlich verlinken können,
wenn der Podcast rauskommt.
Ja, gerne. Wir hatten ja auch
bei unserem letzten Rust-Meetup
in Dresden eine kleine Kostprobe von deinem
Kostmaterial.
War sehr interessant.
Gut, vielen Dank.
Damit lassen wir diese
Folge nun langsam ausklingen.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei geblieben seid
Das war Akronomisierbar
Folge 22
Wir hören uns bald wieder
Wir waren Hendrik
Kean
Und der nächste Podcast
in eurem Podcatcher-Feed beginnt in
3, 2, 1